en france également la propagation d'une
variante delta inquiète et il pourrait
provoquer lé quatrième vague dès le mois
de juillet selon olivier ferrand propos
du ministre de la santé hier alors que
les appels à se faire vacciner se sont
multipliées ce week end la question de
l'obligation vaccinale sera débattu
cette semaine au sénat
on voit tout on voit cela tout de suite
avec notre reporter david khalifa devant
le ministère de la santé
[Musique]
bonjour david vous êtes donc ce matin
devant le ministère de la santé la
question de la l'obligation vaccinale a
beaucoup fait débat ce week-end
notamment l'obligation pour les
soignants ou est-ce qu'on en est est ce
qu'on en sait un peu plus ce matin david
l'écouté valise qu'on peut dire c'est
que le gouvernement marche sur des oeufs
longtemps réticent la légère
recrudescence de l'épidémie due au
vaillant del tarbes a totalement
elle écarte le temps n'est plus dans la
pédagogie mais la prise de conscience en
ce qui concerne elle les soignants dans
un premier temps mais aussi tous les
français olivier véran s impatientent au
vu de la pression mise par l'académie de
médecine qui préconise l'arrêt des
remboursements à des tests pcr afin
d'élever rapidement le niveau national
de couverture vaccinale au cours de
l'été une option qui sera étudié dès
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
la haute autorité de santé elle est plus
direct dans ses propos écouté il est
impératif de se donner un objectif de
vacciner tous les professionnels de
santé tous les intervenants du secteur
médico social indispensable pour ne pas
exposer au virus les personnes qu'ils
soignent accompagnent ou qui sont à leur
contact
il est donc impératif que leur
couverture vaccinale progresse
rapidement
faute de quoi face à un risque de
résurgence épidémique
la question de l'obligation vaccinale
devra être rapidement posé la réflexion
sur l'obligation vaccinale pourrait
s'étendre à l'ensemble de la population
une réflexion qui pousse l'exécutif à se
projeter sur un projet de loi en tout
cas selon plusieurs sources
gouvernementales
en ce qui concerne les soignants tout du
moins une consultation sur le sujet va
être lancée avec la question du
calendrier et gabriela talent estime
possible
une annonce avant un septembre olivier
vallerand de son côté en a remis une
couche hier concernant les soignants
écouter demandé un soignant de se
vacciner c'est pas le pointer du doigt
c'est pas dénigrer le travail qui a été
fait c'est pas daigné le sens de leur
engagement
c'est pas vouloir brusquer qui que ce
soit demandait des soignants de se
vacciner c'est leur demander d'aller au
bout leur engagement au service de leurs
malades et de la santé des gens qu'ils
ont choisi de protéger encore une fois
la vaccination obligatoire quand on est
soignants se sera pas une nouveauté à
une prise de position qui met donc la
pression sur les soignants comment
est-ce qu'il réagisse david et s est
possible vaccination obligatoire
pourrait-elle s'étendre à toute la
population
et bien paradoxalement magali même si
c'est pas un cas général est bien est la
tendance est plutôt positif du côté des
soignants en croire cette tribune
publiée hier dans le jdd 96
professionnels de santé appellent à
rendre obligatoire la vaccination des
soignants pour je cite en finir au plus
vite avec la pandémie pour éviter une
quatrième vague avec elle ses
conséquences humaines sociales et
économiques tous les soignants doivent
être vaccinés concernant la vaccination
obligatoire étendu à toute la population
est bien la question est sur la table il
reste envisageable si jamais la
vaccination continue de stagner ce qui
est le cas c'est depuis ces dernières
semaines en france mais on en est loin
pour l'instant car il faudrait un texte
de loi pour pouvoir le faire et au vu de
la réaction de l'opposition politique et
dernier débat pourrait être houleux si
jamais un tel texte devait arriver à
l'assemblée merci beaucoup david pour
toutes ces précisions david kelly fait
en direct du ministère de la santé à
paris